entre la scène et le grand écran
l'agenda de notre invité clotilde courau
a été très chargé cette semaine
elle est une des vedettes du film la
parenthèse enchantée puis depuis deux
jours le public l'a découverte dans un
nouveau registre celui de la comédie
musicale
jérôme savary a misé sur cette jeune
actrice pour interpréter le rôle
mythique d'irma la douce
clotilde courau a surpris les
spectateurs du théâtre de chaillot
chaillot reportage dominique barrau et
frédérick basile la môme irma reprend du
service
la douce bat le pavé théâtre de chaillot
à paris le tilt de kuro prête ses yeux
de braise à irma ce bourreau des coeurs
mythique que tout s'achète qui jamais ne
se vend
une prostituée que le metteur en scène
érigée en symbole de la femme libérée
personnage de d'irma la douce est une
personnage très fort de femmes qui en
fait préfigure toutes les luttes des
femmes pour leur indépendance pour le
droit à l'avortement pour le droit ou au
à l'utilisation de leur propre corps
comme elle l'entend
millions
gc
tomber amoureux dire mince et devenir
fou de jalousie
nestor le free paie son mac refuse de
partager sa mort il la convainc de
n'avoir qu'un seul client sera lui
déguisé en oscars mais cela ne suffit
pas nestor devient jaloux de son ouvreur
memish avait jamais de toute chose car
si jamais qu'un quart d'heure
en 1956 la création dire main est un
triomphe
elle révèle colette renard ici avec
franck fernandel plusieurs fois reprise
à paris la pièce fait le tour du monde
londres milan new york même hollywood
s'en empare avec shirley maclaine et
jack lemmon dans les rôles principaux
depuis
avec clotilde courau jérôme savary
choisi une voie encore mal assurée les
une actrice qui a du chien
j'ai préféré prendre le risque de
prendre quelqu'un qui n'est pas une
grande chanteuse que le prendre une
chanteuse kim aurait massacré l'émotion
irma la douce à redorer le blason de la
comédie musicale de chez nous ce n'est
pas un hasard si l'oeuvre a été choisi
par jérôme savary
pour sa dernière mise en scène un chalet